the new york times now are reporting
that 18
school children were killed and a
teacher today
in uh uvalde texas
diwali is not far from a place where you
grew up
san antonio shaquille just to visit
there a lot played them in high school
they were in our same district uh
steve's correct you know enough is
enough
places where me and kenny come from
because he's from left right i'm from
the brick city north new jersey
people get killed every day kids get
killed every day
and something has to be done i
understand you talk about back
background checks but
it's a lot that needs to be done because
you know once you do a background check
let's not forget about the underground
market because again places where and
then even charles place where me and
kenny are from
anybody can get a weapon am i right
about that ken anybody can get a weapon
anytime and i'm not talking to ernie
going in the store show your id you know
in the hood anybody can get a weapon so
look if this is sad uh my condolences
goes out as a parent i don't know how i
would react
if i got that call
used to be rules
used to be it used to be codes like you
know kids and mothers and stuff like
that used to be off-limits so
how you how you do stuff like this and
then i heard the kid
uh do something to his grandmother
before he went to school was just [ __ ]
had shot his grandmother before he
opened fire in the school look it was a
sad day
it goes on every day again people where
i come from in northern new jersey get
killed every day chicago a lot of stuff
going on a lot of stuff that shouldn't
be happening steve mentioned buffalo
it's just sad and you know we we all
have to have to do something but we have
to check all avenues don't just talk
about certain things and not forget the
other things
well you know
firstly steve is 100 correct
uh and those who don't know
research steve kerr
in the background where he comes from
and why he feels so
differently about certain things when
you talk about social justice you talk
about uh african-american justice you
talk about
guns and violence a father who was
assassinated father was assassinated do
your research on steve kerr personally
that man
is a trooper
admired him played with him in the world
games was my roommate in the world games
one of my favorite people in the world
firstly secondly
the demonic mind is illogical
so you can't put logic to how that
happened there is no logic to demonic
so
there is no
oh he wasn't in the right mind he was
demonic
let's start there that's a demonic act
to walk into an elementary school and do
the things that he's done and you know
so we just got to pray for the families
uh
and and we have to understand
where this country is right now
in terms of
mental health physical health
and
i see steve said the ability the
availability to get armed weapons
it's been a rough couple weeks man it
has true it's been a rough couple weeks
that thing and book and buffalo shook
everybody up
this thing today shook us up
and what's heartbreaking to me in both
instances
what is making young kids do this stuff
that's what's scared these last two
attacks were carried out by young kids
what is happening in your life
at 17 18 years old it makes you so angry
that you react like this
uh you know we it should be hard to get
guns it's way too easy to get guns the
ghost gun thing is a big issue in this
country
and our politicians they are the worst
example we can follow
this notion that every single thing that
happens in the world we have to vote
among party lines no matter what the
subject is
i'm a democrat i'm a republican i'm
going to go with my team instead of
representing the people
you're supposed to represent all the
people even if you win an election that
don't mean you try to screw the other
people who didn't vote for you you're
supposed to work for everybody but this
stuff man
i never want to get numb to it because
[Music]
you got grandkids i got grandkids you
got young kids you got young kids you
send them to school you think like
never you
you never used to think when you send
your kids to school something bad was
going to happen but you go back to sandy
hook and now it's happening years later
man it's just really heartbreaking and
my thoughts are with all those parents
out there and grandparents because man
you send your kids to school they're
supposed to be safe chucky
you're absolutely right and look i
my wife and i raised six
kids and sent them to school and and
they're not as a teacher and there was
never a there was never an incident
there was never anything like that and
it was they were growing up and now yeah
i have four grandkids i have a daughter
who's a high school teacher
and i
and it scares the devil out of me
it just
because
i can't i can't look at it again i can't
i can't see another
cnn report
that says
this has happened and you think about 14
or 16 18
but school kids elementary school but
you think about it too early
sometimes it used to be like well they
got caught in the wrong place the wrong
time school is never the wrong place
and especially with young kids and
and kenny's kenny always says that's why
prison is full of idiots but they think
they're not gonna get caught and they
got a delusional mind you we can't even
try to make sense about buffalo or what
happened today because
there's nothing anybody can say to you
say i understood why he did that because
it's inexcusable and it's just it's just
a sad day for our country it's just evil
just evil
our hearts go out to all those
in uvalde texas
lebron james
simply has to be changed has to be
praying to the heavens above to
all with kids these days in schools
jason tatum
breaks my heart hearing this news no
parents should ever have to lose their
child praying for the families of those
kids and their teacher it's devastating
[Music]
and chris paul
absolutely tragic we have to do better
as a country
family sending prayers to the families
affected today at rob
elementary
[Music]